remember many months ago when Andrew
Young said hey we got some political
prisoners in the United States everybody
said oh not in the United States of
America the Stars and Stripes and all
this what an uproar but that's about as
far as it went nobody said hey Andrew
who are they and have they happened to
get there why are they political
prisoners we've talked quite a bit on
alternative views about this subject and
tonight we're going to focus on one bona
fide political prisoner in the United
States Leonard Peltier you're heard of
him Leonard Peltier perhaps not the mass
media haven't done too much on him if
anything well we have two people who are
going to fill you in on Leonard Peltier
what happened to him how he was
railroaded into prison how the FBI was
involved with tampering witnesses
harassment scaring of witnesses
doctoring of evidence withholding of
evidence right up and down the line
right through the trial judge can this
happen the United States well it already
has and who else more than Leonard
Peltier well we don't know yet but we're
going to look at Leonard Peltier tonight
very very closely
we have Raul Salinas who is the
representative from the southwest region
of the leonard peltier defense committee
and we're very privileged to have a
cousin of Leonard Peltier Steve Rob ado
can you tell us first for the people who
don't know the history of the Peltier
case sure be glad to well Leonard
Peltier first of all is a Lakota he is a
member of the 1868 Fort Laramie Treaty
in which he is from the section of North
Dakota and presently Leonard is in
prison during two consecutive life
sentences for original charges which
were aiding and
the deaths of two FBI agents on the Pine
Ridge Indian Reservation in South Dakota
which took place on June 26 1975 now on
June 26 1975 there was a shootout that
had taken place in which two FBI agency
illegally entered the reservations to
serve fabricated arrest warrants which
which they were never able to produce in
the trials okay now immediately upon the
agents entering the reservation they
came in two agents one in each of
unmarked car radios and heavy equipment
and immediately a firefight had broken
out as a result of a firefight that had
lasted for approximately eight and a
half to ten hours there was two FBI
agents and one Indian man by the name of
Joseph stoner who to this day as never
we have never had an investigation into
the circumstances of his death
immediately the FBI put out to the media
that militant Indians
hostiles terrorists who were trying to
take over the reservations had killed
two FBI agents and there was a manhunt
out for these so-called Indians
eventually four men were arrested and
charged with aiding and abetting in the
deaths of two FBI agents Leonard Peltier
Dino Butler Bob Robert and a young man
by the name of Jimmy Eagle who later the
charges were dropped because he was
though he was the person in which the
government had claimed their reason for
going in with the arrest warrants which
was for assault and robbery was their
excuse charges were dropped on him now
Leonard was underground for some time
facing already convictions through the
media being put on the ten most wanted
list even before he had went to trial
labeled in him as a as a cop killer as a
slayer when he was captured in Canada
Dino Butler and Bob Bob who were
captured in the United States and they
went on trial in Cedar Rapids Iowa in
1976 while Leonard went on trial in
Canada fighting political asylum in
Canada
feeling that if he was returned back to
the United States he would not receive a
fair trial that possibly be killed and
also in recognition as being a member of
the American Indian Movement he was one
of the leaders of the American enemy yes
yes he was recognized throughout many
communities as as an organizer for the
people yes he had a very responsible job
and was recognized to that effect there
were some of the things he did in the
American Indian Movement what were some
of his political activities that made
him a target for the FBI well I think
one of the most important things to
really clarify in a brief way is that
through the years people have labeled
the American Indian Movement as militant
and radicals to the media that was
presented by the government agencies to
the media we in turn have had to survive
this attack on our people because the
whole philosophy of the American Indian
Movement was to stand for honoring of
over three hundred and seventy two
treaties signed with different nations
in the United States and Canada and in
which today have never been on it not
only the the honoring of the treaties
but the traditional forms of government
of many nations the philosophies of
their culture and their spiritual ways
within their own land base which is very
serious because we see through the
system today that the education system
of America has did nothing but not only
destroy native peoples language and took
in their land base but it's attacking
people around the world such as weeds
such as we've heard tonight about El
Salvador the people are struggling for
their land and they're right this device
to survival and this is what the
American Indian is all about today I
don't like to use a term American Indian
but people are educated to identify us
like that so we'll respect it that way
to a degree but regardless
these here were Leonards duties to learn
those traditions in those philosophies
but at the same time we had to deal with
society in which our people have been
forced to live on how we survive in this
education system today in the society on
how we have to provide for our families
we have to learn an education to do this
and so in order for us to have equal
rights which were which were being
denied minority people throughout every
urban community in the country welfare
programs education programs halfway
houses for offenders orphanages for the
children even I old folks were sent to
foster homes because they could we
didn't have nobody to take care of them
we couldn't even take care of our salads
we had a long worried about the respect
that we used to maintain for our elders
and our children see so these are
philosophies and these are experiences
that Leonard had was going through at
the time of all this this bad media that
was facing our people struggling for
these real changes he was a hunter and
he was a provider some provided for the
people a little more concrete tasks that
Leonard carried out again what Steve is
referring to is the relocation of people
from the reservations into the urban
areas especially during the 50s late 40s
and 50s where native people came to
urban areas and in the shock of being
away from the reservation and then the
lack of employment the lack of skills
the alcoholism which runs rampant in
Indian country and when we say Indian
country we mean through the Americas and
so Leonard was for example in Milwaukee
and alcoholic counselor he had a
people's workshop of auto mechanics to
work on people's cars that were on the
trails and traveling across the land to
support Indian people's causes and so
aside from that his spiritual duties
which encompass being a pipe carrier and
the Sun dancer enabled him to talk to
some of our youth and always took young
people with him on the trail as we say
when he had to go do a job like speak or
gather people for a fishing honoring
fishing ceremonia are those things
it's part of what Leonard's work until
getting back to the case then the other
people involved or charged were also
acquitted all right so as we announced
we were ready to take part to where
Leonard was fighting extradition in
Canada now Dino and Bobby were going on
trial and Cedar Rapids Iowa at that time
and they were acquitted on grounds of
self-defense and misconduct of the FBI
okay it was proven even by Clarence
Keller's testimonies throughout that
trial that day that they did have a
counterintelligence program designed on
the American Indian Movement and they
did believe that they were they were
honest people struggling for social
change and rights for their people you
know I mean we had all these positive
energies come out but see we're dealing
with the third a fourth victim in which
the government had to have a scapegoat
because of the version the diversionary
tactic that they created to discredit
our people through the media to get away
with the acts of what they're not doing
today and that's exploiting the
resources from my land and because
during that same time of the shootout I
think many people always ask well why
did the shootout happen what was going
on but people just don't know that
during that very same time period
Richard Wilson who was in the acting
tribal chairman was in Washington DC
signing away one H to the fine Ridge
Indian Reservation the Black Hills of
South Dakota which is one hundred and
thirty three thousand acres of land and
valued at billions of dollars of uranium
deposits that are being stripped mined
out of there by over 40 corporations
today and today we have a liberation of
Lakota people who have occupied 800
acres of land which is now called the
yellow thunder community which is one of
the richest areas in which the deposits
are are laying and so the government is
very uptight about this at this time
because it's throughout their years
resistance there on April 4th they have
gained the support of not only
international support but over 40
congressmen who are now trying to pass a
bill to the National Park Service's to
clear the land for the Indians use
because everybody knows that there's a
big controversy about who really owns
the hills does the United States
government or does the Indian people and
how long can we be blind to to go along
with the government who has all the
control of all the policies law
enforcement's the laws and everything to
back them up and and how can these
obstacles deny what is really true
because the land does belong to the
native people they are the caretakers of
the land and today we talked about
treaties on how the treaties were
designed to as long as the grass will
grow and the rivers flow and there was
night and day that we would be able to
leave the land freely for our future
generations today we read he was 118 160
yeah what was the agency gate it was a
few years before that because 1868 was a
new treaty as a sign it was the last
cheating but regardless see and then the
American people and in turn people
internationally feel that the United
States is honoring Indian people and
this isn't the case because they use us
through what they call the Bureau of
Indian Affairs and which many of our
traditional people do not believe the
Bureau of Indian Affairs is just a
branch of the United States government
that is funded through every other kind
of little project on how they want to
keep the assimilation and genocide blame
to destroy our language in our land and
that's what it's really all about and
they did a very good job of it because
right now living on the reservation
people think that we have it made we're
getting land lease agreements and money
is coming all the time and the Indians
can just kick back and take it easy but
this isn't so because you go onto the
reservation and you got the highest
poverty in the country going on besides
the ghettos in the communities I mean
you know it's the highest you have for
gasoline it's almost up to $2 for bread
it's over $1 50 in some of the stores
and yet all your stores and your
branches and all all the people who are
leasing the land the Indians are white
ranchers who have control all the
politics that go on in the communities
which amaze and your different
politicians that make up
the City Council you know I mean we have
to deal with all these kind of
confusions that completely take away
from our lifestyles our language it's a
series I'm sitting here talking English
to you I've been robbed my language and
this is a hurt feeling of you know it's
a survival feeling you know and today
our people on I on our last stand to be
educate ourselves and to reclaim the
land in the best way possible against
all these laws and regulations of
policies they've been put onto our
people it isn't a very job that we have
to be forced to become citizens when
we're already a nation alone in our own
land but yet we're not allowed to
practice freedom of religion and they
talk to fear about the First Amendment
of the United States that it has to be
honored among all people but we see
every day that it's being denied us
every day and it's not only native
people because once you've taken the
people in the land based in their
language then you've conquered the
people but you can never come you will
never capture the true spirit of
people's resistance to face the
oppression that is being forced on them
right now because just like the people
in El Salvador
it's a not it's a natural reaction that
you must stand in defense of your land
when you're in oppressed by an oppressor
this your natural duty to stand up and
defend yourself and to protect your land
and protect your women and children such
as Leonard Peltier was doing on June
26th when men women and children and old
people were running for their lives as I
understand it then there was practically
a reign of terror it was a reign of
terror among the goon squads that they
on the with the the people Richard
Wilson's people in support of the Bureau
of Indian Affairs it and it still exists
today still if it still exists today
because they're getting ready for some
other moves or some kind of infiltration
to discredit the people to make them
move for the next big grab is what it
amounts to and how they use people we're
yet to find out such as we did with
Leonard and all the people related to
his case I mean in a six year process
since Leonard's been incarcerated I mean
it's going to be seven years since the
shootout in June this coming June I mean
we we have a total of 12 people who have
been killed we've had we have tens and
hundreds of people who have been
harassed and intimidated
and today it's continuing on with one
key witness such as the name of Myrtle
Poor Bear it was an Indian woman out of
community of Allen on the Pine Ridge
Indian Reservation who the FBI had used
to illegally extradite Leonard from
Canada under false affidavits that they
forced her to sign under a protective
custody plan and the tactic there was
that a members of the American Indian
Movement and Leonard's of the members of
the Leonard Peltier defense committee
were going to go out and kidnap her such
as we were going to take the judge we
were going to get different government
officials in exchange for Peltier and
and people have to remember that with
peaceful people you know we understand
the laws and the pressures in which
we're faced that if we violate the law
we're going to be abused to the courts
just trim it through the federal prison
systems this is odd this is automatic
for people because we got head to
banging against those cell bars every
day that we're trying to feed such as
mataira Chad Marshall who is another
person in which the government used the
same woman Myrtle Poor Bear to illegally
convict Marshall because he was linked
up with Russell Means activism in
relation to liberating the Independent
Commission of Wounded Knee yes
whereas the other two american indian
movement leaders who were let off on the
trial were able to use evidence of FBI
misconduct in the whole trial
leonard was not able to do this no he
was not able come from
leonard wasn't able to have the charge
dismissed on the grounds of his SBI
misconduct and what was some of the FBI
misconduct and some of the strange K
circumstances around in his case that we
I think we can get into a lot of time
there you know but Leonard did he was a
scapegoat he had to be the scapegoat for
we could to make an example before the
people that nobody gets away with
killing law enforcement agency no matter
what they do in terms of police police
brutality in the communities and on the
reservations and around the world as far
as that goes
but Leonard was not given due process of
law none whatsoever because judge Benson
of the trial the federal district court
out of Fargo North Dakota was very open
and very biased to every motion of proof
that
was made for dismissal dismissal or a
new trial okay
he even went through such extremes that
to state even though we had proof to
show that the FBI was lying he would say
the FBI is not on trial here Leonard
Peltier is okay we have to go through
instances to show the state of mind on
how they on how they psyched out the
jury
okay such as with bloody autopsy
pictures that were taken up the dead
agents now it was after the second
autopsy because it was through the
second autopsy that we not only find the
bloody picture machine in which they way
would be before the juries faces but we
come to find out that when each of the
agents just had a bullet in them but yet
the media put out information saying
that the agents were slain and riddled
with bullets they are you know in things
of this nature and so they would wave
this around her and today we have
documents from the Freedom of
Information Act files on the FBI files
that were released to us through that
act we have a documents showing that the
ar-15 and that they're used in Daniel
and Bobby's child as well as Leonard's
trial is April that's that's the machine
gun which is with them this is the one
that's what they've riddled the bullets
with agents we have a document today
showing that it wasn't even the gun it
was just an excuse gun to put in its
place okay let alone a 223 shell casing
in which there were thousands of them it
wasn't even the shell casing that went
into the gun they used as a phony
it was the fabrication of evidence that
was the fabrication of materials and
evidence exhibits as they call him and
the child proceedings and they also
withheld evidence that you would have
cleared oh yes by all means well it was
all regardless of the information
actually was all proven through the
original trial but there was no due
process there was prejudice racism and
they had to have a conviction and they
did it very openly even after the you
know the trial was over prosecutor
Altman would come out to the median
stated that the American that court
system did its duty to protect the
violators who who who offend the law you
know I mean it was really gross to take
but I mean regardless we've taken
Lennon's case all the way to the Supreme
Court to where our last chance today is
what they call the writ of habeas corpus
and the writ of habeas corpus is what
they call in legal terms a 2255 that has
to introduce positive new evidence so
through the Freedom of Information Act
files we have that positive new evidence
that only strengthens the old evidence
as well as exposing over 12,000 pages of
FBI documentation and excuse me 15 and
then there's 12,000 pages that are still
being withheld which is very important
but at the present time our attorneys
have the writ into the typist and it's
ready to be filed very soon and so but
see getting back to the writ of habeas
corpus which I really feel is important
is that it's Leonard's last leg for
freedom you know to receive a new trial
so he can gain his freedom because if we
can't build awareness for people to
become involved with constitutional
rights in which were all bound to those
constitutional rights today are being
threatened to be chopped up such as a
habeas corpus right
last year they had over 8,000 cases of
writ of habeas corpuses and almost every
one of them rejected or deny if any of
them did make it then it had a little
publicity behind it in order to give
that that picture to the people of the
American minds that they were doing it
they were doing their duty but now
they're trying to pass a law to do away
with that right once you get to the
Supreme Court you ain't going to have
any last legal legal remedies to gain
your freedom you know and so we're
dealing with a lot of innocent people
who've already been through these
experiences and just gave up the spirit
to just do the time it was claimed by
the prosecution that the bullet that
killed the FBI agents came from Leonard
Peltier gun whereas the actual analysis
by the FBI laboratory itself indicated
that the bullets that killed the FBI
agents did not match the guy he was
obviously there's a significant piece of
new evidence that is a scandal that he
was convicted on the basis of his false
evidence and that the FBI withheld the
incident was the second point to that it
was claimed that an FBI agent saw
Leonard Peltier was a she
through a scope of his rifle and it
turned out that none of the rifles had a
scope right exactly I was going to get
into that a little bit but plus the fact
that even it was a night anyway right
well no I was doing today it was it
happened in the early morning hours and
it lasted way until into the six o'clock
in the afternoon to where they just had
I mean here you know within minutes
within 20 minutes to a half hour these
guys are on the radio even the
transmission radio calls in the courts
were all fabricated okay the whole the
whole story okay now within a half-hour
here's the National Guard 82nd airborne
armed personnel carrier State Police
city county and city police BIA police
automatically on the scene and you know
that they had a few days from our
investigations of the people that
several weeks before they had BIA police
coming in and was taking out FBI agents
to know the area okay now they already
had plans for what to us go on what was
to happen on June 26 1975 and yet they
talk about these bullets that were
related to Leonard and his gun I mean we
have to go back into simple realities of
the firefight there was a firefight had
taken place who killed Joe Stuntz you
know who really killed those agents has
never been established
Leonard was originally charged with
aiding and abetting with along with all
the defendants but yet when he was
convicted in Fargo they did this happen
to put murder he was convicted of two to
two counts of second-degree murder
there's been a lot of international
support and interest in this case as oh
yes in 1978 when Leonard's cases mr.
Payne Court was our first trip to Europe
myself and Luger was who was one of
Leonard's attorney at the time our whole
purpose was to go to Amnesty
International in London to see if we
would couldn't get them to adopt Leonard
as a political prisoner of conscience we
were very lucky to go there because they
had Leonard's case buried under the
table because throughout all the
processes of his trials appeals
everything all they were was observers
okay because when you're dealing with
Native Nations Native Nations is the
only race of man that has not never
supported by amnesty okay because of
technicalities that I'd like to get into
a little later briefly but we went to
London and we were able to explain their
their reasons why they denied Linda's
case okay where they were quiet within
it was because of the violence so we
explained a self-defense and the attack
on the people they had different point
of views to where they gave us a five
point letter of the main points on why
the Supreme Court judges should allow
Leonard a new trial
okay well regardless we were still
denied the Supreme Court but throughout
that process now amnesty also come up
with other excuses that they couldn't do
it because of technicalities after we
cleared the violence concept okay
so the whole the whole analysis of to
put it really briefly as why they can't
support
Leonard's case technically is because
you're dealing with the nation of people
who are not recognized as a nation of
people by an oppressed government the
United States government under treaty
law and today that comes to be fact
because we look at El Salvador we look
at Puerto Rico who is startling for
nationhood and we see how they miss miss
credited the freedom that nationally
supported Rico by putting them as
terrorists and militants you know I mean
it's people's ways they speak out and
for sure it's wrong but how else do you
get the attention of all the people who
are just worrying about their lifestyles
and don't have time to become involved
with serious things well these issues
you know while you've been to Geneva and
the UN about this case can you tell us
about what that your experience is there
yes well after the trip to our London to
Amnesty International by Stephen one of
our attorneys Luger with there was a
gathering at the Fourth International
Bertrand Russell tribunal at which Steve
again addressed the body there later I
was asked by the Defense Committee to
represent our group represent Leonard in
Geneva I traveled with the International
Indian treaty council as a delegate of a
treaty Council but as a representative
of Leonard Peltier and the
any I was able to address the entire
body on two occasions the international
treaty Council has non-governmental
organization status which is a
non-voting but yet there is a voice and
so I was one of the delegates to speak
of a delegation I addressed the entire
body regarding Leonard Peltier and I was
also able to come in because of my
presentation regarding Leonard and other
Native political prisoners Dickie
Marshall Rita silk Nona Bobbie Reese it
created along with the question of the
indigenous people in Nicaragua created
such an interest at the United Nations
Commission's that we were given a
special session for political prisoners
at that point I allow ate it and and
made some concrete requests of the
international bodies that they take on
some some plans of action regarding
Leonard Peltier we were believed very
successful in that the president of the
body there Romo Chandra from India ended
the conference by alluding to the symbol
that Leonard had become to to the people
by the witnessing of how the many
representatives of Native Nations are
conducted from cells there in Geneva and
he handed the entire session with a poem
that Leonard Roden in a British Columbia
prison in title I and the Indian voice
as a result of that successful meeting
as a result of us very clearly standing
alongside the Sandinista government in
their explanations of the question of
indigenous people which US propaganda
machines have tried to portray in other
ways to us here we the International
Indian treaty council was invited to
Nicaragua in December where the third
assembly on racial discrimination
recourses and procedures on racial
discrimination
was held and again I was asked as a
representative of the London Peltier
defense committee to serve as
interpreter and translator for the
international treaty Council I did not I
was not able to present to the entire
body but since we were guests of the
Nicaraguan government and we had been
very personal friends of commandante
Luna Berto Campbell I was able to do a
very detailed and in-depth interview
presentation on Sandino TV
regarding the case of Leonard Peltier
and Lobby race and Rainey Street here in
Austin so it was very successful and we
have people that we have now we don't
have a committee there in Nicaragua but
we certainly have an Information Center
where we send all our materials and
they're disseminated Mitton a lot of
Nicaraguan children are wearing free
peltier t-shirts and so it was very
beautiful Luz Peltier case is part of a
mainstream of a violation of civil
rights and genocide against Native
Americans for years and years but it's
also part of the continuation of
COINTELPRO program by the FBI which has
been going on for many many decades
against people of all races and colors
and ways of thinking that's exactly what
we're about talking to people wherever
we go all over this country and all over
this world we're trying to say to people
hey you don't know that there was an
operation by scent in 1976 when we were
going across the country to Washington
DC to articulate our grievances to the
US government directed primarily at the
American Indian Movement and other
terrorist groups as they called it we
also need to have people understand that
the US government and its law
enforcement agencies against Native
people had something called operation
garden plot and operation got cable
splicer people need to understand that
these are not figments of radicals
imaginations why were these two of these
were
surveillance gathering and
counterintelligence programs internal
domestically call it domestic
surveillance programs aimed primarily at
Indian people specifically after the
Wounded Knee siege of 1973 from that
point on I believe 74 and 75 was
operation garden plot and operation
cable splicer it's documented if people
read and especially on college campuses
where we think people read but somehow
they don't read with what's out there in
the world people need to read are
there's many books on on domestic
surveillance on counterintelligence
programs during the Fred Hampton case
those were real cases where police
agencies violated civil and human rights
and even according to their own ethics
violated law enforcement ethic codes of
ethics people need to understand that
that's true those are facts and if they
ever allow us for example in the case of
Leonard Peltier very soon we hope to
prove that we hope to prove to people
that the government the FBI and local
levels of police agencies do commit
crimes do violate the law and many times
convict people unjustly and illegally we
had a two-part series on the Greensboro
North Carolina murders of the labor
organizers where it was revealed that
the FBI and a local police etc actually
instigated the violence actually
infiltrated these different groups in
themselves began the violence isn't
there a parallel here to the Peltier
case and the Wounded Knee case well it's
not that the Indians instigated the
violence but rather the FBI themselves
begin it you have some information well
yes we do and and the most glaring
example that we have of course is
Douglas Durham who infiltrated the
American Indian Movement and we have
part of the Amnesty International report
regarding the American Indian Movement
and the FBI
and I was just reading here whereby
documented already is
Douglas Durham's case Douglas derm got
to be in leadership or got next to the
leadership of the American Indian
Movement today Douglas Durham after he
was uncovered as as an informant of the
FBI is today a very not wealthy but very
uh you know comfortable person who
travels on a college circuit and also
paid by the John Birch Society to
discredit groups that are active action
groups social action political activist
groups progressive organizations to
discredit their work and and and you
know he's now supported and financed by
the John Birch Society and we understand
that connection to with all the other
agencies so again like he say there's
very similar that he instigated the
violence the sternum he of course he
will trade the groups and you would find
the excessive so you would find the you
know he would come up with the clever
ideas and the same thing in Leonard and
they knew who was traveling where when
people were going to do this and that
they just had a down pat what's been the
reaction of the mass media and all that
you never see anything in the regular
press about Leonard Peltier or what's
really going on to the Native American
now we have well we have we do have some
developments working with such as
contracts with 20th Century Fox to do
movies on a portrayal and Leonard's life
okay as well as to give some some
accounts of the oppression in the
movement what the people were fighting
for there's a book coming out too if we
have a major novel that is now into the
publisher it's called a crazy spirit of
Crazy Horse or either Crazy Horse spirit
and it'll be a story on Leonard's life
and again it'll be given actual times
dates places and experiences and all the
actual names of everybody is involved
into the book Redford is the one who was
primarily interested in doing movie oh
yeah he's doing a lot of he's doing a
lot of his own investigations right now
really research in the movie because
we're right now I think our commitments
are getting stronger to where he will
probably want to produce and direct a
movie force of course we're in our
contacts we're open to you to anybody
who we want to choose that will tell the
truth in the best way can be told on
film what about the network television
the 60 minutes per instance done well
but presently did this is part of the
work of building the awareness for
Leonard is to get a lot of the American
people to write letters to 60 minutes to
have them take an interest in the
Belcher story such tears to Paul Lowen
water who was within the network Phil
Donahue you know we have connections
into ABC close up people's magazine came
out a year ago in April with an article
on Leonard which was very well New Age
magazine so he's been in the Rolling
Stones he's been in the Village Voice
you know so it is picking up on a lot of
levels but keeping it in the meat in the
local media right now it's the
responsibilities that all the support
groups that are having in their areas
might not like
yes about international support you know
we had like over forty support groups
throughout the countries in Europe that
are have active groups claim okay in the
United States we have approximately
thirty
and throughout this tour since March 8th
in which we've been on a constant
constant public awareness campaign to
support the writ we have established at
least 14 work groups to add to the
national level so I mean we're building
very rapidly and we're the most
beautiful thing of all is to see the
spirit of the people come together on
this serious issue such as Leonard and
standing up to see the spirit that's
generated to keep us going it is very
strong and really you can only say so
much because it's an invisible power
that that we're all looking for in
reality what unity really means what
sharing working together what it means
and I really think through the
experiences we came a long way because
all people knew about before was that
Leonard was put on a 10 most-wanted list
and he was a killer and people didn't
want no part of it you know and now that
we've been able to build awareness
worldwide on him it's growing to where
people are becoming certain that they're
given a chance to hear the case and
that's the realities of it and we just
hope to just keep on in the manner that
we're going our chances of Leonard
winning the new trial is very positive
we don't want to think no other way and
we hope we can build a mass movement
worldwide such as we did with Angela
Davis to stop to be a damn war to stop
the draft because we're going to have to
redo all these things again with we got
plans for people to do the draft again
you know and they're going to be taking
them I mean they're already messing with
the people's the old peoples blood
Social Security and pension checks that
they're getting and with the high prices
of all the energy is going up you know
that we need for lifestyles I mean
people who need to organize they need to
get together and right now I think one
of the most important elements of life
that people need to start learning is
not just look at nature as a coincidence
and things happen naturally but we have
to start understanding on how we are
part of that survival and we have to
start with learning and learning to
respect and use those things together in
the best way possible
instead of putting prices on them and
forget about the people that they
couldn't follow this understanding of
the policy and the education on how you
Carrie here needs then they don't have
no way to survive then what did they do
they steal they become alcoholics and
they just wind up committing suicide
they send them to institutions I mean we
we have a sick Society because we that
think people's got problems
and we set up different little programs
and now all those programs that are
dealing with people's lives are being
threatened too vague ins madness of the
nuclear energy all in nuclear warheads
going into into Europe you know it's
really incredible because right now they
have enough to just to blow up the world
and if we allow the government to blow
up the world
I mean we're gone as people the
generations are no more I mean the
original survived itself in time you
know it'll it'll be a thousands of years
before we gather its strength in order
to have its natural strengths again you
know but what's going to happen to the
people if we allow the uranium thing to
go on and I think examples such as
they're coming out of a lot of different
nuclear Alliance groups such as the one
in Canada two years ago an out through
testing of a mother moved they had to
find out why she gave birth to a
two-headed moose she was eating the
vegetation life and they found out from
the testing that the Iranian chemicals
changed their hormones and if this can
happen to an animal to here's what can
happen to people in reality when we
already know for 20 years in the
community of Oglala in the government
housing that they put up these uranium
chemicals in the wall and which people
are affected by the outcome of that
today and it's just a matter of time on
how it there's a way with each and every
individual because the creations of the
great mystery is really beautiful if we
can just learn to look at it and
valuated what it really has to offer and
living with man-made laws that put
prices on our natural rights to use the
land in the air and the water is
incredible you know that's taken away
from a natural-born right because our
indian people had a way of life in this
land and today we're struggling to hang
on to that knowledge in order for these
children to have a chance in the coming
futures because you look at the peda
government going into the space age is
under believable where we can think
we're going to be space people you know
where's people and we need the air and
we need the water we need
we were going into um unknowing things
that we should not tamper with within
simple sense we don't need to tamper
with ever since they've been to the moon
the seasons have not been the same it's
been a big unbalance and then the earth
is losing its energy squeeze cuz in our
indian beliefs you just can't keep
taking from the earth and taking and
taking and taking using up all those
energies around the world energy is
being used 24 hours a day from the
trucks and the time they take it from
the earth putting it through the process
that's transporting it to the people
getting it into the stores the people
going to work getting their checks
buying these things that they need and
we look in time where does it all go
back it goes back into the garbage that
we've just polluted and contaminated and
we destroy the earth simple process of
understanding but what do we do to
change that I think this is where we're
at and understanding we all got our
differences we've all got our lifestyles
our jobs that we believe in what we're
trying to learn to make a good future
but that's just for our future that's
not for the children because they're
going to be completely different also
you know and to up you know a dream of
what it was to live the life of my
ancestor is a big hurt in many of our
people that they just don't know how to
express so the only way they can express
is this to sacrifice to society and that
is destroying us and start learning what
is really your roots your language the
traditions on how you identify foods
when you're hot when you're fish today
you can't do it because there's nothing
the fishing there's nothing the hunt and
you got to have licenses and then when
you get license you still got to pay for
your hunt you know and there's so many
process people hunt for fur game for
just enjoyment put trophies of the
animals that had a spirit they put them
on the wall locking them into zoos you
look around the world today flying in a
plane you look down and you see all the
land is cultivated into little squares
where they've got fences everybody owns
this and see it just lost the energy see
when you keep taking from the earth and
you build establishments such as this
Italy gives us good example that the
time just takes care of it
it's kind of you know we can reach keep
rebuilding at all we want time is going
to take care of it
but as I children going to be able to
carry on those those knowledge is that
we live by but they're not true
knowledge they're destroying us but yet
we've all accepted it you know we talked
about Constitution but that the
Constitution isn't it
it's natural-born rights from the time
we are born when the time we're in our
mothers wombs and that water for nine
months we come out and be the heir we're
already exposed to all this confusion
out here when before we had a simple way
of what the natural law was see the
medicine world taking somebody else's
eye somebody else's heart is incredible
and that we weren't born to do that we
weren't born to be dope addicts and
shoving needles down our throat confuse
our minds with alcohol just because we
can't take care of our weaknesses and we
had to entertain ourselves we had ways
and medicines everybody had a job
everybody had a different little job
that fitted in not everybody was a
medicine man or a Buffalo hunter or not
everybody can capture the Eagle which
was a medicine of wisdom and knowledge
in arms people like Sitting Bull who
went a hundred years ago tried to take
his people into Canada because of the
oppression that they were being forced
on on the reservation being massacred
and everything else and they captured
and brought him back into you it's the
same thing with Leonard Peltier but only
he couldn't take his people into Canada
they had dead they're struggling for the
last remaining lands they have left in
us right there at home you know and so
this is the reality of it I mean we've
been put on reservations we're claiming
various parts of the country such as the
Black Mesa for the Arizona for the
Navajo Hopi people over here for the six
Iroquois nations you got to New York
State into Canada and over here for us
in South Dakota is the Black Hills you
know just like it is for the people of
the Northwest who are maintaining to
keep the natural fish from becoming
imitation fish from the enhancement
through the fisheries program on how
they're claiming the fish by clipping
their nose from the time they take the
egg they really meant a little processes
when the fish get about this big they
take each and every one and put a metal
clip in a nose so they go out to the
natural environment for four and a half
years come back to the natural ground
and when the fishermen catch the fish
they have to ticket it in the process
and that and this is how to
government's claiming the fish and
they're only going to give you so much
you can't get the regular price but see
those values they're destroyed the
traditional values of our people on the
reservations over there because in the
old day when an Indian person was fish
is his first catch would go as a
ceremony in an offering to the families
or the spirits and then his catch would
come for what he needs to prepare for
those women months that are coming see I
mean we've lost all those concepts of
sharing trading when we all have a
natural right to use the air the water
and all the foods that come with it see
so I think these are serious things that
the Iranian madness is creating a threat
to you know and it's one of the biggest
things and then the war is about to drag
in a natural sense we weren't born into
this world to have to fight wars for
people we were born on this world to
live a life of peace somehow we need to
get back to that that's the reality of
you know